es ist kurz vor halb drei als sich der
vorfall ereignet ein silberfarbener
mercedes kombi so sagen augenzeugen
fährt in eine menschenmenge
er soll auch das berichten beobachter
die absperrung des rosenmontagszuges
bewusst umfahren haben
dann sei er auf die feiernden zugerast
volk massen ist eine kleinstadt in
nordhessen im kreis waldeck frankenberg
in dem ort leben mal gerade 7000
einwohner die rosenmontagsumzug hatte
und 14 uhr begonnen die ersten wagen
waren durch die straßen gerollt
zuschauer sorgten die route polizei und
rettungskräfte sind mit einem
großaufgebot vor ort nach noch
unbestätigten aussagen sollen mindestens
zehn menschen verletzt sein
andere quellen sprechen von bis zu 30
unter ihnen viele kinder
der fahrer des wagens wurde festgenommen
er soll zwischen 20 und 30 jahren alt
sein
erboste menschen hatten ihn nach den
zwischenfall bedroht waren mit erhobenen
fäusten auf ihn zugelaufen
inzwischen ist das sek vor ort und hat
die ermittlungen aufgenommen
peter wagner was weiß man zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt
man weiß noch nicht sehr viel genaues
über die hintergründe ob es absichtlich
geschehen ist ob es ein medizinischer
notfall war ob es ein unfall war ein
technisches so sagen dazu hat uns die
polizei die vor ort ist und ermittelt
noch keinerlei informationen geben
können sie sagt aber eindeutig man möge
spekulationen unterlassen und die
geister natürlich schon eine menge
durchs netz die polizei hat aber aus
sicherheitsgründen vor 10 minuten für
ganz hessen alle karnevalsumzüge
abgesagt die wurden gestoppt aus
sicherheitsgründen und wir müssen jetzt
einfach abwarten wie sich die dinge
entwickeln
ein kollege der vor ort deshalb mindest
13 verletzte gezählt es gibt wohl keine
todesopfer glücklicherweise aber unter
den verletzten
dort sollen auch sehr viele kleine
kinder sein das ist klar es handelte
sich um einen karnevalsumzug
wir verfolgen die entwicklungen weiter
und berichten natürlich auch weiterhin
in den sendungen
vielen dank peter wagner für den moment